j'ai j'ai voulu partir pisser je veux
pas participer
un rachat avec des crochets puisque
jamais présent puisque j'avais très
envie oui c'est bizarre d'être plus
connue cru en effet j'avais un besoin de
reconnaissance de reconnaissance et de
montrer au pubis au public messin d'une
arrivée artistique mon enfance à sa
place je l'avais fédérer la télé et je
dirais plus que tout le monde soit en
cause
pourtant maintenant tu as pensé camatte
mam est remplacée par la mer en plan je
disais régulièrement de céder mais rien
ne pourra espérer mettre en garde contre
les dangers de cette piste du showbiz ma
mère chantait la dame beaucoup pour moi
j'aurais voulu être alarmiste j'avais
voulu leur faire un dessin réalisé mes
parents mais n'hésitez pas à re et ne
désirait pas tout début que je fistules
paris seul et pourtant à l'époque cela
c'est encore aisément d'accord ils m'ont
fait rockets vais me répéter en riant
c'est ta baraque et vers comptait
beaucoup ma mère dormait très peu
j'avais donc un père sévère et d'une
merveilleuse
ils m'ont beaucoup aidé à leur façon
d'un comptoir la mère à se mouiller au
confessionnal à paris j'étais été menés
l'été est jeté j'avais mis une robe en
dentelle pour présenter au jury du télé
crochet les 200 candidats champignons
par les dermatologues
si internet all of us tu peux pour un
post une sur ce casting organisé lorsque
je demandais si je lui demandais
lesquels elle chante elle me dit que
c'est vachement content que tu en sais
ça fait 3 je demandais une nouvelle fois
ce cas la lettre pour julie le hénaff
bref un générique de soporifique je
m'endormis quand l entrecôte à leur
faire la file d'attenté était longue et
pendant que certains se trouvaient au
mauvais visage vous hisser en vocalisant
des -17 ans petit vers des pratiques
plus vertes enfin on trouve deux ans
après mon exercice d'échauffement devant
le jury alors je les ai donné un petit
tube monde 21 certains je peux me
tromper membres nication transport de
contraception farrell qui lui fut dur à
attaquer il faut que j'étais saoul
moitié vous ne savez pas tout ce que
j'ai pu mais j'ai vécu pour raboter ici
j'ai bien mieux joué et craché je me
sentais vaincu la danse une trentaine
attendaient déjà derrière moi qui
pensais qu'on allait lancer bien voilà
devant l'échec
la chaleur humaine mais les yeux miller
et oui je n'avais pas vu la main de
maquillage et pourtant je connaissais
par coeur les eaux de rio l'ecclésiaste
valenti tout est vanité
c'est ainsi que je décrochais du télé
crochet et ils ont vérifié mes
références j'ai pris une correspondance
mon rêve jaillira ravagé et en vérité je
tire une référence à ce qui arrive
je vais vous présenter autre chose dans
un autre registre il ya de la paresse
qui pousse dans le jardin de sa
tendresse du lierre et de la mousse
envahissent et caresser la vanille en
gousse qu'elle glissait dans ses tresses
verts dans ce cénacle rousse son parfum
de promesses à se tourner les pouces les
mourants apparaissent les sentiments
s'émousse quand même outil qu'on laisse
le jardin devient brouste ou se perd sa
jeunesse il la connaît si tous est le
fruit sans cesse il revoit a pris 1,10 à
bouche bée je reste à granville
éclaboussé matin deux nièces et son dos
qui se vouent ce que je lui répète
aujourd'hui repousse centièmes et sans
tristesse
d'autres cris se trémousse elle se tait
sans faiblesse
sans un mot ni secousses et c'est pas
disparaître son silence de des trousses
des espoirs il s'entraîne deux lancés à
ses trousses pour cacher sa détresse n'a
rien à sa rescousse
ça valait sécheresse qui tu meures 11eme
et c'est ainsi que pour des jardins sont
presse